Frank Clark the defensive na Frank have
you been to bed yeah man I've tried but
you know you gotta gotta get back to
work you know when to stop still got my
got it got about an hour in you know I
still puffy but hey man I'm enjoying it
nice - letting it soak in how was his
celebration mine was pretty fun you know
team we got a team party over here at
those and stuff and we just enjoyed each
other's time you know it could be the
last time we were on each other for a
few months you know other than acts it
means just emphasize that you know so he
just enjoyed a time man what was the
scouting report on the Niners offense um
Manny stop the run first you know we
knew born into that game that came off a
really strong performing or running the
ball in this three-punch you know comets
they got in 26:22 and then mo start it
just uh it was really good running
attack mine's pretty strong you know
you know I watching the first half they
was kind of tearing this up with two
runs man and uh and then they you know
got this rook men's work played out of
his mind tonight number 19 Dee Bost
annulus you know so when they got guys
like that and explosive officers you
know those guys are gonna make some
plays but you know we buckle down you
know when they time at it in the fourth
quarter you know when you got an arm
closed our games or win games in you
know it was on defense and you know Pat
mahomes doing you know Pat mahomes
things and you know every everyone are
perceived was in tight ends and you know
set out to uh you know D he was toting
that pill tonight in you know everyone
was just clinking man we all play strong
team bought it yeah I was curious Frank
what you were thinking when it's six
minutes to go and most her gets five
yards so second down in five so they
throw on second down in third down I I
was surprised they didn't run because he
take time off the clock and it felt like
you know they they were able to get what
they wanted for the most part running
how surprised were you that Garoppolo
through those two second and third down
um I wasn't really surprised I mean you
know that they they they was messing up
the whole game you know
honestly doing a pretty good job of it
you know just keeping the room just
lunch and you know a couple of those
drags in the game you know we were
getting hurt on so on you know the guys
um I think that was when Chris mates
that played when he padded one of the
balls down right and then we come back
and you know we get off the field on
third down and I'm forced ed and Pat
goes down the score again so I was like
yeah just bust the game wide open for us
how much did you talk to her in the game
[Laughter]
what am I gonna hear Frank might take a
few days ahead I don't I hope I didn't
see none too crazy but it might take a
few days of evidence you know so good
way to see how it goes did you talk to
Garoppolo yeah I talked to him look you
know I'll talk to some of them but I had
little no you know we were going to come
against him so that no blood in the walk
for sure you know by the time I let him
knock I joined eventually stuff was
pretty cool man it was it was it was fun
you know I enjoyed the Chris Jones was
all over the place last night as well
sure yeah yeah you guys might swim and
you know he does his thing got a nice
you know firing all cylinders and each
of our hyped up you know it seems like
it gives me energy you know it keeps me
going back even when you know he's there
was he like as a player like Chris and
his energy is so positive and he's just
you know everything is a bottom is just
you know it gets beard and good-natured
he just wants to you know see the best
come out of everybody and uh you know
that's all the was and plan will
complete passion I think tonight saw
seen a lot of passion coming from you
know guys and it just showed a lot of
grit
well Congrats Frank that was a great
moment you know if I would have told you
back when my homes got injured you guys
were still gonna win the Superbowl would
you had any doubt back then
I'm not the only only we know what truly
goes on in house you know what I mean
honestly by then you know the best part
about it is when you go to the things
with the teammates and you you make
sacrifices early sacrifice and you know
and and with one goal in mind that's to
win the Super Bowl you know first and
foremost we wanted to win the askew
championship you know we wanted to do
that for our people and and the thing is
we got that done and the other goal is
to win that you know the big one you
know the worlds have been shipping so we
got that accomplishing this a blessing
man you know God is amazing man
thank you Frank we appreciate your time
and celebrate you certainly earned it
Thank You Man I appreciate you guys
hanging out that's Frank Clark Kansas
City Chiefs defensive in got an hour of
sleep there yeah I didn't know he was
miked up but I'm sure he had a few
things to say to Jimmy Garoppolo I like
how he says yeah I'm just letting him
know that you know we're coming after
him I don't think he said it that way I
don't think you said it in like a
low-key hey Jimmy we're gonna be coming
after you might have been a couple of
expletives in there for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]